les gyrophares utilisé sans autorisation
des distribution d'autocollants de carte
de visite avec numéro d'appel la justice
n'a pas apprécié les méthodes
publicitaires de l'association sos
médecins ce domaine
il faut bien que l'urgence est un sujet
chaud en france hormis les rapports
difficiles entre pompiers et samu il ya
la querelle entre les généralistes et
les associations de médecins qui ne font
que les urgences les premiers estiment
que trop souvent clé second détournent
leur clientèle affirmatif des leds
avancions 3 catherine première visée
l'association sos médecins présente dans
45 villes ports que 2 500 médecins on
lui reproche des méthodes commerciales
pas toujours compatibles avec les règles
du jeu ne comblent propre à l'exercice
médical à ce qu'on appelle coup code de
déontologie
vous savez sos médecins est devenu un
fait de société ok ça fait 23 ans que
nous existons c'est nous avons une
mission de fonction publique donc quand
des gens font des recueils utile de
numéro de téléphone eh ben sos médecins
inquiets parce que nous avons cette
notoriété je crois qu'il faut se
rappeler que la médecine n'est pas un
commerce
est tout à fait normal par exemple
qu'une entreprise de quincaillerie ou
une plomberie vente et même 20 avec un
peu d'hyperboles
ces produits car il s'agit de choses
que l'on vend
le médecin a en face de lui une personne
d'urgence n'est pas une spécialité
médicale reconnue mais cela
médecin une grande importance économique
c'est sans doute ce qui fait aujourd'hui
que la querelle soirée animée